hey what's up guys it's Marcus Brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
Hardware review video this one is the
des international or the DSi Wireless
ergonomic keyboard with a touchpad this
is going to be the hardware review I did
review of keyboard not too long ago and
it was a not really at that
full-featured keyboard but as you can
see if I take this up here this one has
a lot of features for me to go over for
you guys so starting with the fact that
it's wireless we go ahead and flip the
keyboard over here you see it has
batteries in here because it uh it
doesn't actually connect your computer
you just take this out this is your
wireless receiver put the keyboard back
here the wireless receiver is as you can
probably already tell USB so I'm just
going to go ahead and plug that in
whoops this plugs into computer blinks a
few times sets up the drivers and it's
plug and play now if we look down here
at the keyboard again it took me like
three tries to figure this out but if
you go to the other side of the keyboard
pretty much like any other wireless
keyboard you actually have to hit that
on switch right there you have to turn
it on so once you've turned it on you
can also adjust the height with these
little height adjustment thingies most
keyboards do have height adjustments so
once you turn it on and adjusted the
height you're set and ready to go so
this keyboard is unique in the fact that
it does have a ton of extra buttons
we're going to start over here on the
right hand side what you see here is a
huge touchpad well not not a huge
touchpad but a very sensitive touchpad I
found I had to do a little tinkering
with the sensitivity of the touchpad it
works almost as well as an actual Mouse
or the touchpad on the laptop but the
the touchpad is is a nice feature to
have on a wireless keyboard you can move
around with it and always have a mouse
wherever you go down here are a number
of buttons and I'll try to zoom in even
more though it's not going to be the
most focused in the world we have an
email button a sorry this is an Internet
button an email client button keyboard
calculator backward and forward buttons
I like that that's pretty cool and at
the top we also have a FN lock or a
function lock for the FN key number lock
caps lock and a low battery which is
nice
cater so if you ever are running low on
battery you'll know that before you run
out in the middle of an essay so
basically the FN button up here the
function button controls a number of
keys along the top of the keyboard and
these are a whole bunch of different
functions so if I have an N lock on
instead of triggering f8 f9 and f10 and
all that you actually trigger these
actions up top so if I press f12 it'll
go into the flip 3d here for f5 press on
f6 it'll eject the CD so there's a lot
of functions little function things that
you can do with this keyboard now on the
left hand side there are even more
buttons as you can see there's a volume
up volume down there is I'm not sure
with that one is actually we have a
play/pause button record stop back bend
forward button those are backward and
forward from media and a left click and
a right click button so this is almost
all you would ever need for really using
a laptop say you're on a netbook and the
the touchpad won't be much bigger than
this so you can actually just attach
this to your netbook and use it just
like that this key actually is not the
Windows key which is right here this key
is actually the media center button
which is actually the same feature as
this green button on the top right-hand
corner of this remote which I showed you
guys and that's basically it now they
call an ergonomic keyboard because you
can see here the angle that goes down
and up a little bit with this keyboard
is kind of an ergonomic angle which is
nice and I found that it does take a
little bit of time to break into this
keyboard breaking it in you can hear
that travel it's not a really thick
keyboard as we can see the keys are not
all that thick but it is it's a nice
sounding keyboard and it only takes
about three or four days before you can
really touch smoothly with this without
making mistakes the keyboard layout is
not that much different now the other
keyboard I reviewed had a number pad
this one instead utilizes a num lock
button and has some numbers written in
rows here kind of like the blackberry
but that is basically it for this
keyboard I think I will definitely like
using this keyboard I've gotten a hang
of it
gotten the hang of typing with it
fluidly it's a nice sounding nice solid
built keyboard the wireless has not been
a problem for me it's never disconnected
randomly or anything like that
drivers setting up was a breeze and I
faithfully it so I hope you like this
hardware of you thank you for checking
this video out thanks for watching if
you have any software ideas or requests
feel free to subscribe and message me
through youtube because i do alternate
back and forth between software and
hardware videos but that has been
basically it for this keyboard review
video I hope you liked it and if you
haven't already hit that subscribe
button and you can also check out DSis
link in the description thanks for
watching this video guys
have a nice day peace